I should wait.
You're listening to radio,
the podcast from New York public radio and public radio.
[inaudible],
c n n p. R.
Everyone Jad here from radio lab. This is radio lab, the podcast,
something of the different this week and we're not going to do science.
No big ideas today. Actually, I want to introduce you to an amazing musician.
Can you do like a loop loop so I can just make sure that that's getting, yeah.
[inaudible]
if you happen to catch our war,
the world shows was our live show that we did in Minnesota.
You may have noticed some really beautiful,
lush Chillo textures threaded all throughout that hour.
All those textures were played live by Mrs Zoe Keating.
Who is right here next to me. Hello?
Hello Chad. How are you? I'm great. And we're sitting in San Francisco,
so this is a bit of a of a, of an excursion,
but lucky enough I get to sit here and listen to you play because during the
performance there was a point where we actually stopped chatting and you just
played for people and it was amazing. People loved it,
but it was only people in the audience that got to hear it.
So this gives everybody else a chance to hear it too. So, uh,
maybe you could start by explaining all of these blinking lights that are near
you. Like you're sitting here with, uh, with, uh,
a gorgeous kind of Mahogany colored cello, but then behind you are,
is a laptop and some computer electronic type stuff. So what,
what exactly is all this? Um, well,
I'm basically doing layered tello by,
I'm playing cello and then using a combination of a foot controller and a
computer to record each layer and then play it back for the audience. So, um,
what I might do is, uh,
I'll just sort of play a loop and then you can see how it happens for mind your
way here with different girls. Okay. So I basically,
I got this foot pedal and I'm going to record a single line like this.
Eh,
sometimes you get a little artifacts in there, but it's kind of Nice.
[inaudible] [inaudible] then I might add another one.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
so that can just play and I can wander off,
chat with the audience or have a drink.
It's like little bits of you from the past. Keep coming into the present. Yeah,
yeah. It is like that. Yeah. Yeah. And sometimes you know,
hearing your past over and over again can get a little boring.
So you might want to start changing it.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I might take them away. I think that it's,
no,
so essentially it's like you can create multiples of you and then sort of just
using your feet.
You can make some of you go away and then some of you come back. Yep. So,
so w when, when we're, when we're listening to these pieces,
you're hearing these giant washes built and suddenly they drop out and you hear
just one of the lines and then all of a sudden they're back.
There's a sort of a, a bode baseline.
All that is sort of be crafted with your right foot. Yep. Okay. It's pretty,
you know, it's pretty simple. It's, yes. It's,
it's neat to see that you're funneling this just slightly passive version of
yourself into the present over in Dover. It's Kinda quantum in a weird way,
you know, I never thought of it that way. But you are
[inaudible] for better or for worse because if you make a mistake,
like I make lots of mistakes,
then that mistake is repeated over and over and over and over again. Yeah.
We supposed to make you very comfortable with your own mistakes.
At a certain point it does. You can't do this and be afraid of failure.
So you were in a band called recipe Tina. Tell me a little bit about that.
How do you go from being a classically trained cellist to a rock, rock star,
EAD kind of cellist? Like what does that, what is that transition like?
I didn't ever see it as a transition. It just seemed completely natural. Yeah.
I mean, I like rock music and, um, I think probably if I played guitar or bass,
I'd probably be playing guitar bass, but I just happened to play cello.
Well before we talk too much, what are you going to play his first? Uh, well,
I'm going to attempt to play a new piece, which, um,
that doesn't have a name. Okay. Um, it's, it's going to be on my new record.
Well, whenever you're ready.
Um,
eh.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Wow. That's kind of how that works. Okay. Lord, let me just,
before I fond too much, let me just plug this in. Wow. That didn't,
it's so much more fun when you can have all these layers and you can control
them. Yeah. I'm just curious about,
you said you didn't have a title for that piece that we just, yeah.
What does a title really do for a piece like that?
Like I guess what I'm asking is where,
what do you see or feel or where does a piece like that begin?
Does it begin as just a purely musical line or is it a picture in your head or a
feeling? It's a feeling. It's all really abstract.
That's why I have a really hard time coming up with titles because, um,
I don't like to assign specific meaning. It's cause it's, it's, it's a,
they mean everything and they mean nothing.
And so as soon as you put a title on something that gives it a meaning.
And so sometimes I like to make up words or have something completely random,
kind of like the madlibs version of making song titles,
but it usually starts as an idea. And, um,
so there'll be some sort of like emotion about it and I just try to keep that
emotion and see where it goes in a song. And that's all it is really. Yeah, no,
you were doing all kinds of things.
I didn't actually catch all of it because I closed my eyes and just sorta like,
I just sort of got taken with all the wash of sound.
But you're doing all kinds of things that were not strictly a traditional cello,
Boeing or you were hitting the chelates.
Can you explain to you how you were making all those sounds? Well, um,
I only have one cello and I like to make rhythms, so, so I might do that.
Somebody like, which is like hitting the bone,
the side of the cello or I might use my palms and go like this.
And um, things like that. And then also I might, um,
do a little tapping things like, you know,
or I might, um, do little like things like that.
And it's, I'm taking sort of, um,
I like to think of it as like a DJ scratch approach to the teller. And, um,
you know, you make all these like little electronic sounds,
but I like to see how many kinds of electronic sounds I can make using a 17th
century instrument.
At first I wanted to get a whole orchestra to play this music.
And I actually got, like, when I first started doing this, um, I,
I started working with a couple other musicians to see if I could like translate
the ideas. And I was like, how do you write this? You know, like,
how do you write? Like, okay, take the back of your instrument,
turn it around and hit it with your, how do you write that?
And then how do you write like, like this, like Boeing, the,
the wood directly. What's the notation for that?
I guess I could make something up, but, um,
I like the immediacy of having a computer. Like if I have some sort of idea,
I can just do it. I don't have to explain it.
Like you asked me what my music is about. Yeah.
I have to try to put into words some abstract feeling and then it's already
like, it's removed. Yeah.
Tell me about some of the projects that you're involved in right now.
Cause you're, you're, you're on your own,
you're doing your own stuff and releasing those and,
but you're also what mostly I'm working in film right now,
like just writing music for, um, film scores and something I really like doing.
Um, so I'm finishing up a documentary right now. It's called ghost bird.
This is about the woodpecker. Yeah. Oh, every filled with picker. And, uh,
and then last year I did, I got into horror,
which is very strange for me cause I,
I'm a very sensitive person and I can't actually watch her, but, um,
what sorts of cello gestures would picking? We'd end up in a horror film like a,
you know,
[inaudible]
oh suddenly can you hear it? Yeah, sure. Yeah. Or like really detuned
Ooh, was that Carrie? Yeah, that was piggy that squeak at the end.
But isn't it amazing that you can just do that? Like the, the,
that was what was really interesting about your show with the, um,
more of the worlds thing.
Like you could just add like one note and then add another note to it and
suddenly it's ominous. Can I hear another? Sure. Sure.
Um, I could do, let's see.
Does anything really listen to you? Tell me, um, I'll, I'll get out of your way,
but if you could introduce it just, and tell me what, sure.
What you think you're going to play. Um, let's see.
Let me think about it for a minute. First can, I mean, I can make a request,
but I don't know if it's one you've prepared for sure. Um, album number two,
Sun, the sun will set some saying, yeah, this one was that, is that,
is that something that's easy for you to plan? Extremely easy. Oh,
I love that son. Sure. Okay. I'm going to just give me one second. All right.
So to introduce it, uh, this piece is called, it has a name.
It's called that the sun will set pretty well.
Woo.
[inaudible] okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that piece is just beautiful. It's just so pretty. It's really fun to play.
Yeah, I have, I love that piece. Um, when did you start on the cello?
When I was eight. You're eight? Yep. And when you started, was it, I mean,
you certainly weren't looping and doing all these kinds of things.
How was it at the beginning? Uh, I really liked the sound of it. You know, like,
I don't know if this will come through on the, on the microphone,
but I went to see this.
I am
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I have two notes playing together, but they make a shape.
They make this sort of like wave policy shape and I would just,
I would just like get lost in that for a long time. Play the fifth. Yeah.
How did you begin? I mean, what,
what sorts of cello stuff were you doing at the beginning when you play?
Were you a classically trained musician? Yeah, I did all the standard things,
you know, play some Bach play in an orchestra. But, um,
I suffered from really debilitating state of fight to the point where I couldn't
play in public at all. I would never, I would always think it'd be fine,
you know, and then I would get up there and, um, I couldn't hold the bow.
Like I couldn't remember how to play the cello. It's like I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be able to do it. Like, I actually did have a concert once where I,
um, I got up there and, um, my,
my hand is shaking with seeking so much that I just,
I couldn't even get it on the strings. I mean,
and then I just dropped it just dropped the ball, dropped the bow, my fingers.
That didn't make any sense. It was just really, really, really difficult for me.
And so it was like my,
the more I progressed as a musician and it became just the stick,
terrible nightmare. Um, so I decided not to,
not to pursue classical music as a career and I instead went to study liberal
arts. Um, but in college,
all my friends were filmmakers and dancers and so it was just inevitable.
I would start playing the cello in all their little films or I would, you know,
be like the piano would company meant to the dancers. Okay. And so I would,
I would just improvise and they would dance. And that new,
that new version of yourself where you're just playing improvised stuff and it's
dancing. And this film developed that easier. Yeah. I never,
I've never had stage fright doing that. Like, if I can play my own music,
I'm fine. Huh. So, and that's the difference.
It's if it's the notes coming out of your head versus out of Beethoven said,
yeah, there is something about, um, it's not me.
It's like I have to recreate something that is,
that already exists and supposed to be a certain way.
And there obviously is some part of me that just rebels against that.
So w w when did you get this idea? [inaudible] I mean,
the idea to take a cello and run it through computer and loop it and all that.
Well, I lived, um, you know, I always live with musicians and um,
most of them would be rock musicians or electronic musicians and they'd always
have like little pieces of gear lying around. And I'd be like, oh,
I'll try that, you know,
let's try the Ceelo through this delay or let's try the Telo through this.
Vocoder you know, and I would, I think I spent,
I don't know how many hours doing that, just just like me, you know, me.
The, wow. What was the, well exactly was it that you were with, you know,
it was, it was that um, the cello is such a linear instrument.
Like pianists can play all these nuts at once,
but with cello I can play like two notes at once and um,
with the looping pedal you can play some notes and then you can play notes on
top of it.
So it's like you were playing more than one instrument and I could also hear all
the things I was doing badly. That was really interesting.
I imagine it must have been interesting because you mean because of the stage
fright, you know, to hear the things that you didn't do right.
Come back and then come back, come back. Yeah, but they didn't bother me.
It's interesting because you really,
you never get to fix your mistakes from the past.
Like very rarely happens when it does. It's great moment.
But with living you do, because say you record something and it's a mistake,
you might be able to add something to it that might make it sound right. Ah,
it's like that thing I've heard jazz players say where they say like,
if you make a mistake, do it twice.
That's interesting. Have you ever heard that? I haven't,
but that makes total sense though. Can I hear another? Sure, sure. Um,
let me switch that fence again. Can you introduce this piece? Uh,
this piece is called, um, legions war.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
well, wow. Thank you. So that, that was a,
tell me the name of that piece one more time. Um, legions were legions were,
and that was on your second CD, right? Is there a third coming out? Yeah.
Um, I'm trying to finish it in between finishing up these movies, but I really,
really hope to have it out this summer. So,
and if people want to know more about you and hear more of your music,
where can they do that? The best place is probably my website,
which is Zoe keating.com.
Or if you just type Zoe and cello into Google,
I think I'm the first thing that comes up. No kidding. That's pretty cool. Yeah.
And we'll also link to you@radiolab.org and, uh,
and maybe put some clips up if that's okay with you. That'd be great. Thanks.
Okay. So can you, can you take us out with something? Uh, just improvise.
Okay. Okay. Yeah. Improvise.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
that was so freaking cool. That has an ending. Wow.
I guess that's it for us. Um, thank you Zoe. And uh, this is jad signing off.
Radio lab is funded by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting, the National Science Foundation. Hi.